lunettes épaisses, coupe simple, vous voyez le topo.
Je pense que j'avais des amis uniquement parce que je partageais mes devoirs.
C'est la vérité.
Mais une fois à l'université,
j'ai été capable de me trouver une nouvelle identité,
et l'intello devint la fille populaire.
Mais c'était le MIT,
donc je ne sais pas si j'ai beaucoup de mérite.
Comme ils disent là-bas :
« Ceux qui sont bizarres sont bons,
mais les bons sont bizarres. »
(Rires)
J'ai tellement changé de matière principale que mes conseillers m'ont dit
que je devrais avoir un diplôme en études aléatoires.
(Rires)
Je l'ai dit à mes enfants.
Et avec les années, j'ai gagné de nombreuses nouvelles identités.
J'ai commencé comme inventrice, entrepreneuse, innovatrice sociale.
Puis je suis devenue investisseuse,
une femme dans les technologies,
une enseignante.
Et plus récemment, je suis devenue une maman,
ou comme le dit constamment mon enfant :
« Maman ! » jour et nuit.
Même mon accent était embrouillé,
son origine si dissimulée,
que mes amis l'appelle « Rebecanese ».
(Rires)
Mais se réinventer peut être difficile.
On peut souvent faire face à beaucoup de résistance.
Quand j'avais presque fini ma thèse,
j'ai été piquée par la mouche de l'entrepreneuriat.
J'étais dans la Silicon Valley,
et donc écrire une thèse dans un sous-sol ne semblait pas aussi intéressant
que démarrer ma propre entreprise.
Donc je suis allée voir mes parents coréens très traditionnels,
qui sont là aujourd'hui,
pour leur faire savoir
que j'allais laisser tomber ma thèse.
Vous voyez, mes frères et moi sommes la première génération à aller à la fac,
donc pour une famille d'immigrants, c'était quelque chose d'important.
Vous pouvez imaginer comment cette conversation allait se dérouler.
Mais heureusement, j'avais une arme secrète,
qui était la liste du revenu moyen de tous les diplômés
du programme de thèse de Stanford,
et celui de ceux qui avaient abandonné
leurs études à Stanford.
(Rires)
Cette liste était très sûrement établie par Google.
Mais ma mère regarda la liste, et dit : « Oh, fais ce que tu aimes. »
(Rires)
Salut maman.
Maintenant, ma quête d'identité n'est plus de trouver ma tribu.
C'est plutôt me permettre
d'adopter toutes les transformations possibles de moi-même
et de cultiver ma diversité intérieure
et pas seulement extérieure.
Mes fils ont maintenant trois ans et cinq mois,
et ils sont nés avec trois nationalités
et quatre langues.
Je dois mentionner que mon mari est danois.
Comme si je n'avais pas assez de chocs culturels,
j'ai décidé d'épouser un Danois.
Et je crois que mes enfants vont être les premiers vikings
à avoir des difficultés à se faire pousser la barbe en vieillissant.
(Rires)
Oui, il va falloir travailler là-dessus.
Mais j'espère vraiment qu'ils trouveront que leur multiplicité
leur ouvrira et créera beaucoup de portes,
et qu'ils pourront utiliser cela afin de trouver des points communs
dans un monde aujourd'hui de plus en plus global.
J’espère que plutôt que d'être anxieux et inquiets
de ne pas coller à une étiquette
ou que leur identité devienne un jour sans importance,
qu'ils se sentent libres d'explorer
et de prendre en main leur identité et histoire personnelle.
J'espère aussi qu'ils utiliseront leur combinaison unique
de valeurs, langues, cultures et connaissances
pour aider à créer un monde
où les identités ne seront plus utilisées pour aliéner ce qui semble différent,
mais plutôt, pour rassembler les gens.
Et plus important encore, j'espère qu'ils ressentiront beaucoup de joie
en traversant ces territoires inexplorés,
parce que c'est ce que j'ai ressenti.
Maintenant, concernant ma grand-mère,
son dernier souhait fut aussi sa dernière leçon pour moi.
Il se trouve qu'il ne s'agissait pas uniquement de retourner en Corée
et d'être enterrée là-bas.
C'était pour reposer auprès de son fils,
décédé longtemps avant son départ pour l'Argentine.
Ce qui comptait pour elle n'était pas l'océan
qui séparait son passé et son nouveau monde,
mais c'était de trouver un terrain connu.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)